hi everyone welcome to the document ai
session
i'm sudhira banguri and i lead the
language and doc ai product suite at
google cloud today i'm very glad to be
joined by nadia a senior outbound
product manager at workday
a quick run through of the agenda today
i'll provide a brief overview of
document ai and how we convert documents
into business-ready structured data
we'll then dive into work-based approach
using doc ai to gain operational
efficiency so let's dive right in
for centuries documents have been
foundational to our societies
we record histories establish laws
legitimize trade launch companies and
confirm identities with documents
the computer age has introduced the idea
of digital documents which now serve as
a backbone of our modern societies
the power and value of digital documents
is immense
but for all the value that these
documents have created digital documents
still require work not only in creating
them but in processing these documents
every company today processes digital
documents
the size and burden will vary as will
the importance of those documents
but no company is able to escape the
reality of what we call digital manual
labor
if you're watching this session you
probably know what i'm talking about but
let me give you a few examples
digital manual labor comprises the work
that many of us do but almost never
shows up in a job description
it is essential to the vast majority of
today's business workflows
and it captures the value of data in
those digital
documents it is also candidly a pain
validating checking
sorting
keying copy pasting normalizing etc
and with the continued growth of digital
workflows and digital transformation
we expect this burden to only grow
for example as the healthcare industry
has digitized the ratio of healthcare
administrators to physicians has grown
35x
representing the enormous and important
work of ensuring that our healthcare
records prescriptions
pre-authorizations and medical bills all
documents are processed properly
so let's talk about how we want to help
our customers and their employees
manage the toil of digital manual labor
document ai represents google's
investment to bring the power of machine
learning to processing documents
you may have even seen this slide before
in fact we've shown this slide to
hundreds of customers and to be honest
sometimes their reaction is not very
enthusiastic and that's because many of
them think that they've already solved
this problem with other technologies
awareness of the paid for digital manual
labor is not new for decades now
smart people have been working to
capture structured data from digital
documents
ocr key value pair extraction
template-based readers and other
technologies are now commonplace
even so far that the term ocr has become
a shorthand for document extraction more
generally
in short if you tried digitizing
documents you probably used one or more
of these or services that are built on
them
but if you've tried using those
technologies you've probably realized
that they aren't the full answer for
most business workflows
while they do what they say with
increasingly higher accuracy they also
create new kinds of digital work
pre-processing post-processing growth
management and template management are
new kinds of toils and tasks that now
often shift the shift burden to it
departments
the reason why these legacy technologies
require supporting labor manual labor is
because understanding a document is much
more than reading a document
in order to properly understand a
document humans do much more than read
words off the page
they bring knowledge of what the
document is and what it should contain
they are able to interpret different
structures and wordings
they can connect what they are reading
to other data in the workflow or even
from google to make sense of it
and so on it's actually an incredibly
difficult task
one that is harder to automate than many
expected that's why with document ai we
have made it our goal to turn documents
into business ready structured data
as we work closely with our leading
customers
we realize that the part of the problem
is that legacy technologies are solving
a problem that is too simple
yes you can
get some structured data with a table
parser
but we have heard that what customers
are looking for is business ready
structured data
in other words they're looking for a
technology that will read documents in
ways similar to humans
they are looking for the confidence that
when they start to automate processes
they are not signing themselves up to a
different kind of digital manual work
when we say business ready what do we
mean
of course for each customer and each
business process the definition of
business ready will vary
but as we have moved models into
production with more and more customers
some consistent themes have emerged
at a high level customers have asked for
an end-to-end solution that is business
ready for any document and business
ready for any document workflow
business readiness for any document
means the doc ai can process a given
document and deliver structured data
that a customer can immediately trust
and use
we have summarized this as 4cs
consistent and accurate extraction
complemented with other data
cross-border ready and corrected as
needed i will spend the next few minutes
covering what we mean by each of these
but solving the business problem doesn't
end with understanding a single document
that is why we have three more c's
which speak to the importance of
supporting the entire document workflow
the ability to custom build new
processors for a wide range of new or
long tail documents
the ability to comprehensively
orchestrate and execute tasks across the
document workflow
and the ability to constantly improve
models i will come back to these at the
very end of our time
i want to spend some time going deeper
into the first four c's that we
mentioned about and how we can get
business ready data from a doc ai
processor
again these are those four c's
consistent and accurate extraction
complemented with other data
cross-border ready and corrected as
needed
first let's look at consistent and
accurate extraction
one of the wonderful things about
documents is that they start as blank
slates
they can take on any structure or design
of course this is also what makes them
hard to automate but for any given
document type you may encounter a wide
variety of formats versions concepts
words etc
and humans are naturally able to make
sense of these differences but machines
need special training
and that's why we are investing in what
we call specialized parsers machine
learning models that are built
specifically for any given document type
here's a sample output from the document
ai console and you'll see that the
course schema supplier name supplier
website invoice id don't actually show
up as text on the document anywhere
instead these are concepts that our
models have been trained over thousands
and thousands of samples to recognize
and then find
from one invoice to the next and this
can be especially powerful when there
are say multiple addresses which belong
to the supplier versus the receiver
specialized processors can make these
distinctions that are ultimately the
difference between business ready data
and more digital manual labor
as you may know we have begun our
journey with specialized processors
focused on lending and procurement
workflows in fact we are actively
building towards a library of parsers
for all the world's most commonly used
business documents and today we are glad
to announce our latest edition with
contract ai specialized document
processors what we call the most
valuable documents on the planet
for more details please check out the ai
100 session
we are also proud to announce that we're
continuing to expand the lending doc ai
portfolio and now have about 50
specialized processors available for use
and there is much more in flight which
we will be rapidly releasing over the
coming weeks and months
okay on to the next scene complemented
with other data
this is something we are especially
excited about
when the information is missing or
ambiguous on a document like a missing
address or entity name a human often
needs to search for it often on google
with dark ai we are bringing the power
of google search to help customers
understand their documents
that means that the same google
knowledge graph
that helps you find the name or address
or phone number of a restaurant you want
to go to can enrich your document
extraction with the right name address
or phone number
here's a sample receipt from a
colleague's trip to europe if he were
filling out an expense report and needed
to input merchant name he might struggle
to choose between some good options
angelina angelina paris angelina rivoli
you might say take some time to go to
google and find the right entity name
that is angelina paris
or he might guess and move on
potentially creating headaches for the
finance team down the line
with document ai there is a better way
our native integration with google
knowledge graph means that we can
deliver both the specific text from the
receipt as well as google's best
understanding of the actual name of the
restaurant that operates at this address
here's another example and in this use
case the supplier address does not
appear anywhere on the receipt and this
creates a choice of either extra work or
potentially incomplete or inconsistent
data
however google google knows that the
office depot in los gatos with this
phone number is located at 151666 los
gatos boulevard so docker is able to
enrich this field which would have
otherwise been returned empty
we are very proud to announce that this
google knowledge graph integration is
live with many of our core dock ai
processors from procurement to lending
the extraction of information from
invoices receipts bank statements pay
stubs and more is now enriched with the
power of google's knowledge graph and we
are actively working to roll this
capability out for all relevant fields
across our entire portfolio of parsers
the next c is cross-border readiness
specifically the ability for companies
to process documents in every language
that they do business in
few of our customers do business in only
one country or language and their doc
processing workflows need to scale with
them and at google we have taken a two
pronged approach to this problem first
we are building custom specialized
processors for some documents in high
volume languages think spanish invoices
of french identity documents and second
we are building on google's
long-standing leadership in machine
translation by integrating translate
capabilities directly into our
specialized processors
this means that customers will get
instant access to specialized doc
processing in hundreds of languages
here's an example of a french invoice
and again you see the full benefits of
schematized pricing as fields like
supplier name supply address are
extracted from the document even though
the field names themselves don't show up
as an aside i want to quickly highlight
the amount of work that has gone into
the computer vision models under like
doc ai it's no small fee to be able to
read say the supply address of a
document of this quality in addition to
our specially trained models our
integration with google translate means
that customers can now process documents
in over 100 languages all of those
supported by the google cloud translate
service critically while the specially
trained models are of highest quality
the translate based models have
demonstrated minimal quality losses
we're also pleased to announce that many
of these cross-border investments are
now available to our customers
specifically procurement.ai
the procurement dock ai team has
specially trained additional models in
six languages primarily european ones
with procurement.ai we have also
integrated the translate pipeline into
the invoice and expense parsers
expanding support to hundred-plus
languages this feature is in preview
today and is also actively being rolled
out to all relevant specialized parsers
in future
the fourth and final c for today is
corrected as needed this highlights the
reality that for many workflows we will
always need humans involved to some
degree and while we can ease the burden
of digital manual labor we still need
humans to be the final reviewers of
critical and challenging dot processing
steps our reviewer interface brings the
intuitiveness and the simplicity of
google interface design into the hands
of doc reviewers and we display the
document alongside the structured data
extraction highlight areas that need
more attention enable easy and
on-document corrections and much more
dock ai then returns both the original
and updated data as part of the json
output
as customers grow their dock processing
operations it is essential that they are
able to definitely manage the wide range
of settings and priorities and tasks and
resources that they oversee and that is
why we'll build the manager interface as
a control panel for all of these needs
and this is directly integrated into the
dock ai section on the gcp console
we are now glad to announce that the
full range of human in the loop
functionality described below is now
fully available for lending dock ai
expanding the coverage that already
existed with procurement.ai
we are aiming to make this fully
available for all of our dock parsers
not only for extraction but also for
splitting and classification
to recap
here are the summary of all the new
announcements that we've made today
with procurement.ai we have google
knowledge graph integration in ga we
have custom trained models for high
volume models in ga we have translate
integration in preview
we have the lending dock ai with six new
ga parsers and 30 more in preview
we have contract dock ai now available
in preview
we have google knowledge graph
integration available on blending.ei and
we have human in the loop integration
also available in ga for lending doc ai
we also have expanded language support
for procurement.ai
for the last 10 minutes we have walked
through many investments we're making in
improving document processing workflows
and we realized that for our enterprise
customers these workflows are almost
always a part of a larger business
workflow procure to pay expense to
reimburse
foreign qualification insurance policy
underwriting and so on and that's why we
are proud to work with israe and sas
companies that are leaders in helping
customers execute these business
workflows one fantastic example of this
is our collaboration with workday who
has been pioneering the very use of
document ai to reduce digital manual
labor in daily business workflows
today i'm very glad to be joined by
nadia a senior album product manager at
workday nadia has been a fantastic
collaborator and thought partner for
document ai and i'm very excited for you
to see how she and her team have brought
the best of doc ai into the hands of
their users i'm glad to introduce nadia
to tell us more about their journey
hello everyone my name is nadia axa i'm
the outbound product manager for workday
expenses and i'm so excited to be here
today
in the five years that i've been with
workday expenses i don't think i've ever
met a customer that has not asked how we
are driving operational efficiency
through machine learning
whether it's ocr or
intelligent insights
automation is top of mind for our 1350
plus exponents customers
today i'll be sharing a little bit about
what we've been able to accomplish with
the help of doc ai and more excitingly
where we are headed next
but before we go any further let me tell
you a little bit about workday
our mission is to deliver value through
our enterprise management cloud that
brings financial management spend
management human capital management and
analytics together in a single cloud
our vision for the travel and expense
solution is to put the employee at the
center of a touchless experience by
eliminating manual entry and cumbersome
review and approval processes
earlier this year
workday combined google cloud's
procurement dock ai solution with our
own document processing machine learning
models to deliver an elevated experience
for our customers
these customers can now scan receipts in
five languages and have the most
pertinent details auto populated for
them
with 98 of workday expenses customers
either creating or editing
expenses on workday mobile in the past
year this update made a lot of people
very happy
let's take a quick look at the receipt
scanning in action
we are in a demo environment and we're
going to use the expense receipt
scanning service powered by google to
scan a receipt for our user dagmar who
is an office administrator in germany
for the sake of this demo i have
switched her preferred language to
english
dagmar went to a local print shop to
copy documents and she saved the photo
of the receipt on her mobile device she
clicks the scan receipt option which
takes her to her photo album from there
she selects a receipt that she wants to
upload
the scan process is kicked off and it
only takes a few seconds to complete
now that the scan is completed let's
take a closer look
on the receipt we see that the merchant
is not mentioned we see the merchant
address
we see the date
we also see the amount as well as a
currency
now let's scroll down further
the date amount as well as currency are
populated as expected and to our
surprise the google knowledge graph used
the merchant's address to derive the
merchant name how cool is that that's
definitely going to save her time
to complete the expense report
submission dagmar will need to select an
expense item and i know what you're
thinking workday when will you default
the expense item for her well that's
something that we're working on right
now and we hope to release it very soon
at this point denmark can go ahead and
select the expense and add it to our
expense report
alright hopefully you were also just as
impressed with the magic of the
knowledge graph it's going to continue
to be instrumental towards delivering a
differentiated experience for our
customers
now some of you may be wondering why
this is even a big deal i mean
you saw that we scanned a few fields
they could probably be entered manually
pretty quickly
and if you're thinking that way that's
okay
i've had to explain this before so let
me use a say a few numbers to do the
same thing
in 2019 so pre-covet era
our customers uploaded
27 million expense receipts into workday
if the manual receipt entry on average
takes about three minutes
that is 1.35
million hours of time spent doing
tedious tasks
that adds no real business value
and postcovid we actually expect this
number to be even higher
also keep in mind that people are not
hired to do expenses
and as an expenses pm i will be the
first to admit that no one even enjoys
doing expenses
so in other words in this day and age no
one should have to enter expense
receipts manually because that time is
better spent on doing value-added work
i hope this helps you understand why we
are so excited about this and with the
help of the procurement dockyi solution
we expect to save customers hundreds and
thousands of hours and enable them to
get back to doing their real jobs
now i'm going to talk a little bit about
what's coming up next for us in relation
to doc ai by the end of this year our
customers will be able to scan receipts
in a hundred plus languages
and although that itself is a giant leap
forward we are not stopping there
we're looking at a number of
opportunities to create a touchless
expense entry experience and i want to
share a couple of examples with you
we will support fields um that are
handwritten so for example you have a
meal receipt that has a tip that's been
handwritten we'll be able to scan that
and auto populate that for the user so
that they don't have to worry about
entering that manually in addition we'll
be scanning additional fields such as a
record locator and that's often found on
a trip itinerary and what that will help
workday do is to use that as a unique
identifier and link that to an existing
credit card transaction that's already
been imported into workday to accurately
match the two so that the user does not
have to worry about that
these enhancements and many more will
further reduce the burden of manual
entry and simplify expense submission
for our users
in addition i want to mention that aside
from expense submitters
approvers and reviewers are also two key
additional players in the expense to
reimburse process
today many of our customers
painstakingly review expenses line by
line and they do this to identify items
that may be out of policy or incorrectly
coded
with the help of procurement dockey i
worked will be able to provide
additional intelligent insights that
will help the approver and reviewer
um reduce the time that it takes to get
through that process and that in turn
will reduce the time to reimbursement
because everyone wants to get their
money asap right
so how are we going to do this well the
google knowledge graph will help us
identify the category that a business
establishment belongs to and this
information will help determine if the
expense is reimbursable so for example
you have an employee that goes to an
adult entertainment club and expenses
that transaction as a meal that does
happen believe me
so we will take that insight about the
business establishment
um and that's provided by the google
knowledge graph and we will flag that
expense for the reviewer so that they
are able to make an informed decision on
whether or not that expense should be
reimbursed
another common problem that approvers
and reviewers run into
is ensuring that the receipt is itemized
so that it satisfies the requirements of
their back office audit teams
with the help of doc ai we will plan to
determine if the receipt is in the
format and has a content that satisfies
a criteria for valid documents
now workday is also looking at doc ai
for supplier invoices and contract
scanning
to improve document understanding and
enable users to make better decisions
more quickly
our customers are incredibly excited for
what's to come and i want to thank
sudhira and the dockyai team for the
invaluable work that they've been doing
that's it from me now over to sedera
thank you so much nadia we couldn't be
more excited about what you are building
and how it will help people with the
work they're doing every single day
we spent most of our time today looking
at how doc ai can take a given document
and extract business ready structured
data and specifically how this comes to
life with receipts and expenses at
workday
before we go i want to spend just a
minute on last three c's these are
investments we are making in dog ai that
will ensure that customers document
workflows are big business ready as well
custom processors reflect the reality
that many customers will need
process will need to process proprietary
or less common documents in addition to
those for which there are specialized
parsers and we want to make it easy for
those customers as well to quickly build
high value high quality processors that
work perfectly well alongside the rest
of the dock ai processors
comprehensiveness refers to the need to
address more than just the document
extraction and review and there are many
challenges upstream and downstream in
the document workflow and we want to
help customers solve those two
and finally we want to make sure the
docker is getting more and more helpful
as you work with it more not only are we
committed to constant improvements in
our underlying models but we also want
to allow our customers to improve upon
them for their specific domains
here are a few highlights of the things
we're working on related to these areas
while we didn't have the time to go into
all of these exciting details today we
look forward to sharing more with you as
we continue our journey and perhaps at
next 2022
with that here are a few ways that you
can learn more and even get hands-on
with doc ai and please get in touch with
us via your google cloud contacts or
directly at doc ai hyphen external at
google.com
thank you again for joining us today and
we look forward to working with you all
on all of your document related
challenges
you